1 2 ok il est 6 heures 50
je dois partir j'appartiens au festival
de cannes je voulais faire à ma évacuer
commencer maintenant et répondre déjà
une question dès maintenant mais j'ai
pas le temps en fait je retarde les deux
groupes bon j'ai tort former le train a
plusieurs fers que moi puisqu'il leur
retard de 20 minutes
alors cette partie là on va la faire en
voix off en fait je me sens que les
blogueurs ils sont hyper à l'aise pour
parler comme ça alors caméras devant
tout le monde
moi j'ai un petit peu plus de mal donc
je vous dis pourquoi pas faire cette
partie là en voix off voilà pendant je
suis dans le train tranquillou bill ou
pourquoi pas de format je pense que déjà
il ya la volonté de ne pas m'enfermer
dans une case spécifique et il y avait
aussi une forme de lassitude du fait
d'avoir tous ces formats là et en fait
quand je sortait une vidéo ça devait
forcément rentrer dans un de ces formats
je pense que youtube évolue énormément
aussi est autant les formats bien clair
à un moment ça allait avec ce qui
plaisait aux gens et à la plate forme et
aujourd'hui c'est plus trop le cas j'ai
l'impression donc j'essaie de faire en
sorte que l'on s'intéresse plutôt à moi
ma manière de parler ma manière de
m'exprimer
mon mode de pensée et les sujets qui
m'intéressent plutôt que à des formats
très spécifiques est-ce qu'on rémunère
les pattes sur des feats c'est une bonne
question
alors la plupart du temps n'ont quasi
tout le temps non en fait c'est vraiment
comme si vous invitez un pote à dîner
quoique juste le dîner les films et
c'est un peu ça le délire j'ai eu
quelques créateurs qui rémunère quand
leurs vidéos et sponsorisé moi c'est ce
que j'ai toujours essayé de faire de mon
côté également mais par exemple j'ai
fait un truc avec ben nevers et un truc
avec les odeurs voilà dans des vidéos
qui était sponso et les deux m'ont
rémunéré maintenant j'imagine que ça se
fait aussi en fonction du placement du
concept etc
j'imagine aussi que ça dépend de la
place de l'intégration de la marque
aussi moi je me vois mal rémunérés ou
est rémunéré pour un fils dans une vidéo
où il ya une intégration par exemple
norvégienne à la fin qui est totalement
décorrélée la vidéo donc voilà ça c'est
pour les vidéos sponso mais pour toutes
les vidéos qui ne sont pas ceux conso ou
alors j'ai pas les bons potes sur la
plate forme et dans ce cas là vraiment
juste les autres youtuber prévenez moi
et soyez pas avec moi s'il vous plaît
voilà
il vient
[Musique]
que j'ai vraiment envie de perdre ma
raison quand ma manière de réfléchir
ma logique tout ça quoi bilan de cette
petite pandémie bilan agent c'est fini
je passe sur malheureusement pourquoi je
fais moins deux vidéos sur la philo ça
revient assez souvent je pense que je
fais moins deux vidéos sur de la philo
pure mais je pense que la plupart de mes
vidéos pousse toujours à la curiosité à
la réflexion en tout cas j'essaye et
c'était peut-être ça le plus important
j'ai fait une trentaine de coups de fil
donc on a vu une trentaine de concepts
ensemble c'est vrai qu'il en reste plein
et je dis pas que j'en referai pas un
jour mais globalement plutôt que de
partir de la pensée d'un philosophe et
voir comment elles résonnent dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui
ben je préfère partir du monde
aujourd'hui et voir ce qu'on pourrait
dire dessus c'est un sens qui est de
plus en plus naturel pour moi et ça fait
écho à cette volonté aussi de ne pas
avoir de format en fait j'ai bien dormi
ok donc je viens d'arriver à cannes et
on m'a amené dans un restaurant terrasse
qui appelle chez albane cinquième étage
ok d'accord dans l'ascenseur les gens
que je ne supporte pas je dirais que
c'est les gens qui m'écoutent pas en
fait
donc il part en vacances à sion avec eux
souvent ces gens qui parlent beaucoup
d'eux parce que par elles sont pas dans
le sens pas dans les changes en fait on
pas dans le dialogue
et ça j'ai vraiment eu voilà globalement
les gens qui n'écoutent pas cette
burrata est la meilleure burrata que
j'ai jamais manger tu proviens simon
très bon faire deuxième prise est alors
oui on passe couleur quelle vidéo je
suis plus fier attention la bufala reste
j'attends que la bouffe à la vidéo dont
je suis plus fier c'est donc à une
tempête qui arrive donc on bouge la
tempête katrina
2012 le film c'est maintenant les my
lady and co et voilà la chambre
incroyable incroyable
olala petit bonsaï on va répondre à
d'autres questions
on me demande si je me dis toujours une
fois par jour oui si tu médites toujours
une fois pareil voit toujours est ce que
tu sais bien attacher déjà papillon
proprement way savoir bruno c'est très
bien après c'est pour desserrer surtout
que parfait à ses patrons sony canon je
n'aurais pas plus pas de soucis
t'inquiète kate ont rapport à la
philosophie aujourd'hui et en quoi il
était utile au quotidien
mon ouverture d'esprit je pense que ça
m'a sam est vachement à être plus
ouverts et en fait à ce que chaque
nouvelle idée chaque autre opinion je
vais vraiment la prendre comme une
opinion et je peux être contraints et ne
pas l'accepter mais j'ai vraiment être
choqué en fait d'un truc j'ai rarement
réagi avec l'émotionnel et ça à mon avis
c'est grâce à la philo parce que on voit
tellement d'opinions différentes
tellement de vision du monde différente
extra qui se confronte sans jamais y
mêler un affect en tout cas de mon côté
youtube ou twitter
écoute j'ai découvert twitch donc il ya
un peu plus d'un an maintenant sauf que
cette plateforme est incroyable youtube
au moins ça reste ma maison ça reste là
où je fais les trucs qui sont les plus
importants pour moi mais twitch j'adore
en fait j'adore le fait de pouvoir être
vraiment moi-même
le fait de pouvoir voilà vous montrer
des choses que je n'aime pas sur youtube
parce que je sais qu'elle ce truc de
live et que ça va être juste à un moment
et que ça va pas rester dans le temps
etc
et ça c'est quand même hyper libérateur
moi ça me permet de faire beaucoup plus
de dinguerie sur twitter sur youtube et
là j'ai envie du coup de d'investir un
peu plus de mon temps sur twitch et
peut-être monter quelques projets un peu
plus ambitieux sur toute la pression
c'est vraiment au stade de réflexion
comment gères-tu le célibat szlachta
solitude pendant ces deux questions très
différentes la solitude
j'avoue je le vis
assez bien c'est j'ai fait une vidéo là
dessus il ya vraiment cette différence
entre solitude et loneliness et vraiment
je le vis comme solitude après comment
je gère le célibat j'ai été très peu
célibataire dans ma vie donc là je le
vois vraiment comme l'opportunité voilà
de tester des choses faire des
rencontres de découvrir des
personnalités vivre des instants et même
de tester des choses en amour en fait
c'est aussi l'occasion de découvrir des
choses qui semblent acquises dans le
principe de ce qu'est un couple dans le
principe de ce qu'ils aient une relation
etc
je pense que jette pas la maturité pour
des consciences et choses là avant quand
j'étais célibataire
là je pense l'être donc j'essaie de
tirer le profit de ça quand tu rester
vivre sur paris des voyages en tête en
france ou à l'étranger
j'avoue ans notamment parce que je suis
seul et que j'ai pas la tâche
j'aimerais bien deux villes en fait
qu'ils sont mes villes préférées en
dehors de paris dans lequel j'aimerais
potentiellement vivre un jour pendant
une petite période de temps je sais pas
si j'irai au bout de ce truc là parce
que si j'arrive à y aller de temps en
temps et c'est ça me suffira peut-être
peut-être que je m'en contenterai mais
j'avoue que vivre à new york où vivre à
tokyo l'expérience me botte
comment vis tu ta notoriété voilà je
trouve que je suis à un niveau
parfaitement notoriété pour ça que quand
je sors appareil que je me promène
extras dans une journée on va pouvoir
par exemple le reconnaître c'est pas
trois quatre fois c'est très bien je
vois certaines personnes que je connais
ou qui se feront connaître beaucoup plus
bas parfois c'est un peu trop quoi pas
que c'est trop mais je veux dire voilà
on peut plus vraiment se promener
innocemment s'enferre gare des combes et
dans un espace public on doit faire
attention parce que on va pouvoir nous
reconnaître même si on vient pas nous
voir et donc en fait tout ce que je fais
peut être vu par quelqu'un qui va
pouvoir ensuite le raconter on peut pas
par exemple
être sous avec des potes à 5 heures du
matin dans la rue et faire des bêtises
quoi c'est un exemple c'est un truc que
je fais souvent après ce qui est
compliqué est paradoxal c'est quand même
temps je me dirige vers ça il faut d'une
certaine manière que je me dirige vers
ça parce que si ma chaîne ne crois pas
en fait elle décroît donc en fait
inévitablement je vais vers
potentiellement si si tout ça marche et
je vais toucher du bois parce que quand
même on a envie que ça marche mais
potentiellement je vais vers un truc de
notoriété qui va me déplaire mais ça va
avec le job parce que ça va aussi avec
plein d'autres choses qui elle me plaît
c'est bien le fait d'avoir une
communauté
le fait de vous faire du contenu que je
kiffe le fait d'avoir plus de moyens
pour faire ses contenus posons une
question maintien question pourquoi vous
me suivez
qu'est ce qui fait que monsieur vraie
question voilà bon je pense qu'on va
mettre le le smoking dans 20 minutes je
prends une petite douche je met le smoky
ok donc là qu'est ce qui se passe on
fait 20 m pour ensuite aller sur le
tapis rouge montée des marches et c'est
assez incroyable sur l'a31 à ce que tout
va bien dans cette voiture
parfois c'est un peu plaisir si on
faisait quoi ton stress là mes cheveux
non mais tu disais que en rose on va
sûrement enfin wayne sapp à une faute
aussi que la rate ses armes ont la
chance de ta vie qui échoue d'un
photographe stéphane pour ne pas le
nommer
steph steph entre nous on l'appelle
steph on arrive il va prendre une ou
deux photos et c'est tout quoi donc tu
as un regard crisper un truc machin tu
es mal lindelof c'est permis c'est fini
c'est fini voilà un témoignage est
équivalent mais non la photo est pas
l'attention d'étudiants même pas
chauffer ses cheveux ou festoche aura
honte des photos par les sorties ok on y
est on voit les marches là bas on se
trouve à réussir à marcher et ne pas
tomber
c'est la question incroyable ce qui se
passe
soit parce que c'était ce procès nous
paraît bizarre c'est bizarre le coma il
ya une femme ananas devant un petit peu
de frais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok je fais une petite pause je suis
remonté à la chambre juste pour changer
mes chaussures coup je vais répondre à
une nouvelle question c'est une question
qui est très intéressante
en fait c'est particulier parce que moi
j'ai l'impression qu'il me reste tout à
faire j'ai l'impression que d'une
certaine manière voilà je suis je suis
très loin du succès de la réussite de
tout ça je n'ai pas l'impression d'avoir
réussi en fait d'une certaine manière et
même temps je fais cette vidéo et je
suis au festival de cannes donc il ya
certains éléments très précis très
concrets qui me laisse penser que bah si
mais qu en fait tu as quand même
accompli plein de choses mais dans ce
que je ressens j'ai l'impression de
succès pas le cas et ça ça me saoule un
peu j'aurais aimé le me sentir un peu
plus accomplie mais en même temps je
trouve que le fait de ne pas me sortir
accompli ça me pousse et c'est un moteur
à faire plein de choses je dois me
sentir au début ça c'est sûr et je peux
voir à ressentir à la fin parce que j'ai
pas l'impression que c'est la fin à tous
et la fin que je le sais pas peut-être
que c'est la fin parce que genre dans
trois mois ça sera fini pour x raisons
je peux au courant mais voilà il ya
serait qu'à ce double feeling de j'ai
quasiment 31 j'ai pas fais un truc big
et en même temps si je suis ici c'est
que c'est pas nul ce que j'ai fait une
autre question avant redescendre
pourquoi pas un rapport
bah tout simplement parce qu'on est dans
une relation parra sociale j'ai fait une
vidéo là dessus je ne suis pas ton ami
où je ne suis pas votre ami je sais plus
où je parle des relations parent social
nos vu que c'est une relation parent
social
on est par rapport à l'est une dernière
question est ce que j'ai un planning
pas vraiment je sais que par exemple
tous les mardis soirs je live mais j'ai
pas le nombre de postes où le nombre de
tweets que je faire sur instagram
twitter etc
voilà ça j'ai pas j'essaie de me
vous sortir une vidéo par semaine le
mercredi un switch par semaine minimum
le mardi je prévois un petit peu mais
vidéo à l'avance tout cas les sujets
pour pas me sentir un peu perdus ou
akure pouvoir planifier des choses j'ai
bac en gelée planifie forcément ça peut
être mieux mieux travailler mais non
j'ai pas de planning rigoureux comme tu
l'entends
voilà je vais retourner et j'espère
qu'on va aller sur dance floor ce que
l'europe apprend pas mal de temps et
j'attends qu'une seule chose c'est
d'éclater ce dance floor
non je vais vrai il ya une vraie contre
le monde ma part en tout cas ok donc là
on vient de rentrer de soirée il est
alors là il les chevaux l'heure d'aller
ouvrir les primes psychiatre 4h36 je
veux pas continuer ma évacue tout de
suite mais c'est juste pour vous tenir
au courant de ce qui se passe cette
vidéo date est cette vidéo et rêve
attendait alors je descends 1,15 à temps
je descends avec toi pourquoi prendre à
ceux qui attaquent un ascenseur
politiquement parlant est ce que je suis
plutôt de gauche ou de droite
alors ça c'est une grosse question c'est
marrant parce que cette question bon
déjà n'est pas facile j'imagine sur
internet dans le sens où je sais que
forcément suivant ma réponse je vais
décevoir des gens c'est sûr mais c'est
intéressant parce que dans les
commentaires de beaucoup de vidéos
notamment les vidéos du type seriously
donc c'était y'a quoi c'était il ya deux
ans trois ans quelque chose comme ça
j'avais à la fois des gens qui disaient
que j'étais d'extrême gauche ou très à
gauche est à la fois des gens qui
disaient que j'étais très à droite
voilà j'ai jamais eue extrême droite je
crois la vérité c'est que une des
valeurs les plus importantes pour moi
c'est la liberté
c'est une valeur que j'ai envie de
préserver c'est quelque chose qui est
très important à mes yeux
la vérité c'est que cette liberté dans
tout ce qui est social
ça se traduit par des mesures qui sont
souvent considérés comme étant de gauche
et quand cette liberté est toucha de
l'économie ça se traduit souvent par des
mesures qui sont catalogués comme étant
de droite moi dans ma conception des
choses c'est du libéralisme en fait mais
pour moi le vrai libéralisme il n'est
pas qu'économique il est aussi sociale
l'idée c'est juste une émancipation des
individus et de leur liberté et donc ça
va de leur liberté d'entreprendre à leur
liberté de se marier avec qui veulent ou
leur liberté de changer de genre et être
reconnu pour ça
donc là un au petit matin j'ai pas le
temps là il et je dois partir dans 20
minutes
j'ai pas pris de douche j'aimerais
apprendre petite douche et en prendre le
train
je voulais vous répondre à une question
mais j'ai une question
une petite question rapide s'entretuent
parfois du centre l'imposteur oui de ouf
par exemple la shoah cannes pourquoi
chacal en fait ça me fait trop plaisir
merci marois réalité c'est orange qui
m'a invité parce qu'on travaille
ensemble cette année tous mes proches ma
canne hockey dernière le conseil mantra
qui a changé ta vie rien et le plein
mais celui qui m'a le plus marqué
dernièrement c'est priori cet avis
sinon c'est les autres qui vont la
priorisation place c'est à dire qu'en
gros si toi même tu dis pas ok c'est
quoi ma priorité qu'est ce que j'ai
envie de faire tac mes décisions et vous
si toi tu fais pas staff
en fait les autres faits qui font de
proposer de me proposer de faire s'ils
vont proposer de faire ça ils vont me
proposer tel projet et ces machins et tu
va les suivre et s'est tue à dire oui
oui ça a l'air cool machin est donc
c'est les autres qui vont prioriser ta
vie à ta place
voilà c'était qu'une seule nuit c'est
l'heure de partir on attend à voir le
majestic
merci beaucoup j'ai toujours ça quand je
quitte un hôtel ou en herbe angie au
revoir aux lieux c'est fou c'est fou
cette petite parenthèse enchantée la
merci c'est aussi grâce à vous tous a à
orange aussi évidemment mais si vous
étiez pas là je serais pas là comment je
gère le succès j'ai pas tant que ça à
l'impression de le connaître pour être
honnête
du coup je gère comme je gère d'habitude
c'est juste qu'il y à beaucoup plus de
sollicitations et donc que je réponds à
très peu de chose pour préserver quoi en
tout cas je voudrais pas le mot gérer
parce que gérer ça implique une forme de
problème et j'avoue j'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir de vrais problèmes
aujourd'hui
voilà j'ai cette chance là après
peut-être que ça ça sera différent un
autre niveau de entre guillemets succès
un big up d'ailleurs à mon agente qui me
sauve littéralement la vie est ce qu'il
va y avoir deux prochains épisodes de
t'imagines si je sais pas je trouve
qu'on arrivait un petit peu au bout de
ce format de ce concept etc
je voulais faire un tout dernier épisode
avec tom mon mon comparse tom aguilar du
meilleur podcast est en fait ça me
faisait marrer de faire une vidéo genre
s'est pas tu imagines si cette image in
sous ses mains sous dans le sens ivre ça
me faisait rire ça me faisait rêver à ce
que je vais aller au bout de cette idée
je sais pas mais ça me fait rire
voilà tom et moi on soit là à imaginer
des trucs mais en étant souhait que ce
soit le dernier
après tu imagines si tu imagines sous à
vous me direz ce que vous en pensez
je rentre à la maison j'ai pris un j'ai
pris un chauffeur vtc là entre la gare
et chez moi qui pense qu'en fait bas qui
m'a expliqué pourquoi l'humain a créé le
virus pourquoi les politiques ont créé
le virus et comme quoi c'était pour
préparer une nouvelle ère en fait un
nouveau système etc
je ne sais pas quoi dire
ça me rend triste en fait vraiment
triste parce que j'aime imaginales pas
cette personne qui pense qu'on vit
vraiment dans un monde de merde quoi
alors ya peut-être des raisons penser
qu'on vit dans un monde de merde mais
pour moi ça sera en effet chaque 4% là
ok bon va falloir être vif
est ce qu'on aura le retour du meilleur
podcast un jour je vais appeler tome il
répond jamais j'ai certes à l'heure
comment répondu aux critiques de la
vidéo sur la banque de france entre
parenthèses sinon trop fort
merci beaucoup il ya un décalage entre
la vision qu'on peut avoir parce que je
les ai sentis même dans mes potes
en fait mes potes qui ont dit ouais bien
la vivre la banque de france et tous ces
particuliers tout a vu les retours
machin en fait ya une petite minorité
qui parle très fort qui a fait beaucoup
de commentaires et ça nous évitons dans
les commentaires ça se sent par contre
si on regarde par exemple le taux de
like de la vidéo d'habitude monte au
delà et qu'il est de 98 99 % donc ce qui
est énorme et je vous en remercie merci
beaucoup
ça compte beaucoup pour moi la haye 2
92% c'est vraiment pas catastrophique
georges considère pas que c'est une
mauvaise vidéo en terme d'accueil
ce serait aller à l'encontre des
chiffres en fait de dire ça vous serez
tenté de dire ça mais pour moi ce serait
un billet et ça voudrait dire que je
retiens beaucoup plus un commentaire
négatif fin de mandat positif
or si je suis juste non je pourrais pas
dire ça y est les vidéos que j'ai fait
qu'ils ont eu un taux de legs de 60%
hélas oui effectivement c'est
problématique c'est pas le cas je trouve
de la vidéo que j'ai fait tom qui me
rappelle ouais mon vieux
je suis en je suis en train de tourner
une faq là et il ya une question qui te
concerne tome est ce qu'on aura le
retour du meilleur podcast un jour le
oui c'était la réponse je suis
totalement en direct matin ok donc
c'était vraiment trop dur de dire juste
oui quoi oui il y aura de nous voir mais
un podcast un jour quoi moi je pense que
oui il y aura un nouveau mais en podcast
un jour exact voilà bah ça fait plaisir
je te prend pas plus de tant d'hommes je
t'embrasse très fort par ailleurs je
disais quoi
maintenant je les comprends aussi mais
autour bien quiproquo sur ce qui est
attendu de moi moi dans aucune vidéo je
n'ai jamais donné en fait toutes les
options ai dit voilà ça c'est une pensée
on peut avoir d'autres pensées et ses
machins et les voici
j'ai jamais fait ça sur aucune de mes
vidéos je n'ai jamais fait ça et je pars
toujours du principe que mon audience
elle est capable
sa forme et au delà d'une vidéo de
comprendre les tenants et les
aboutissants en tout cas de les chercher
d'aller à leur recherche etc
voilà j'ai jamais à ce niveau là
considéré que l'audience
buvez mes paroles entre guillemets et
que prenez tout ce que je disais comme
acquis si j'avais une chaîne qui était
purement en divertissement écluses et du
thé vidéo de divertissement genre je
mange bleus pendant 24 heures ç'aurait
été différent il ya plein de chaînes
youtube qui parle d'économie etc
vous êtes beaucoup à avoir cité par
exemple eureka très bon vulgarisateur
d'économie moi c'était pas ça le but de
la vidéo et je les dis dès le début j'ai
dit voilà je suis là
je voulais savoir je voulais comprendre
ce que le directeur de la banque de
france pensait et quelle était sa
politique qui était son point de vue et
c est pour moi je trouve ça important
d'avoir son avis à lui parce que c'est
un décideur
voilà je suis bien conscient qu à mon
avis cette réponse va pas satisfaire
beaucoup d'entre vous mais mais c'est
pas grave je ne peux malheureusement pas
satisfaire tout le monde mais dans tous
les cas j'espère que vous apprécierez
les prochaines vidéos quoi qu'il arrive
et une dernière question où en est-on
projet de cuisine et souvent encaissant
laisse tomber avec question qui revient
très souvent comment tu t'es organisé
pour ta retraite négative au n'est pas
et revient très très souvent cette
question et je réponds jamais et là non
plus je veux pas répondre parce qu'en
fait pour moi le fait de trouver tout ça
le fait se renseigner sur ça ça fait
partie du chemin initiatique du truc
et j'ai pas envie aussi de vous donner
quelque chose et que du coup vous des
gens se retrouvent là dedans que ça
ruine un petit peu l'expérience ça
revienne à la fois l'expérience de
locaux qui se retrouverait avec plein
d'étrangers et sa ruine votre expérience
en tant qu'étranger houba vous serez
avec plein de gens comme vous donc voilà
j'ai pas envie de trop en dire quoi
moi j'ai parlé mon expérience j'ai
jamais donné de trop de détails sur ce
que c'était parce que voilà je pense que
ça chacun de trouver son chemin trouver
des trouver des choses qui résonne pour
nous mais j'ai pas envie d'arriver avec
un package et voilà moi j'ai fait ça et
donc du coup plein de gens se retrouvent
à faire la même chose tu sais je pense
pas que ce soit intéressant on arrive à
la fin de cette vidéo je voulais vous
dire un dernier truc j'ai sorti des
podcasts quatre épisodes de quatre
minutes pour parler du don de moelle
osseuse et déconstruire toutes les idées
reçues qui peut y avoir autour du don de
moelle osseuse on a besoin de donneurs
en france c'est même pas on a besoin de
donneurs mais on a aussi besoin de gens
qui s'inscrivent en fait en tant que
donneur on appelle ça des veilleurs de
vie et les gens qu'on appelle quand on a
besoin d'eux c'est très difficile
d'avoir une compatibilité en termes de
moelle osseuse
donc plus on est inscrits et plus on a
de chance de sauver deux genres c'est un
podcast est très important pour moi
g j'ai un ami auquel d'ailleurs j'ai
dédié un des premiers coups de fil
c'était le coup de fil 4 qui est décédé
d'ailleurs d'une d'une maladie du sang
donc voilà c'est problématique de don de
moelle osseuse me touche
j'en ai beaucoup parlé sur instagram et
twitter vous êtes certains et certaines
à m'avoir envoyé bab le fait que vous
êtes inscrit en tant que veilleurs de
vie des lieux de vie etc
c'est un beaucoup touché j'en ai pas
encore parlé sur youtube donc voilà
c'est chose faite je voulais un liant
description c'est juste quatre épisodes
de 4 minutes et ça peut vous parler ça
peut voilà dédramatiser beaucoup de
choses autour du don de moelle osseuse
et peut-être vous inciter à vous
inscrire au registre pour vos questions
toutes ces questions c'était sur
instagram
donc merci monsieur vous là dessus je
pensais qu'on allait plus revenir sur ce
qui s'est passé ces six derniers mois
mais c'était pas forcément votre souhait
dans les questions
donc voila moi je je pense que je
referai une faq tous les six mois je
trouve ça pas mal je t'embrasse très
très fort et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo
gros bisous
six restaurants en rentrant avec la mif
maman une question pour toi est ce que
j'ai toujours été sage et sans ça fait
plaisir
maintenant qu'ils sont cons masseur
passage aujourd'hui